what are the first things an actor has
to do once they get to LA I realized
that you're going to be rejected a lot
and that it will take longer than you
ever thought I came with a two-year plan
and I thought that was giving myself a
lot of extra time but I've been here
four full years this is going into my
fifth year and only in the last year did
I start to have any type of decent
success and by that I mean that I could
keep food on the table regularly but I
came I think that if you come you have
to decide am I going to cut all ties
with other careers and do this or not
and I chose to not have a day job and
it's made it more difficult but I
couldn't have reach any success without
it when you came here four years ago how
many IMDB credits did you - and how many
do you have now 100 I just passed my
100th imbd credit and still nobody knows
who the hell I am so you can make a lot
of movies without actually bursting into
the big public consciousness I think
that's another thing actors need to
understand you know so I've done a
couple of TV movies for a Hallmark
Channel and they're great and I'm glad
to be at them and they were yes they
helped but they do not change your life
and they don't change your career
there's so much noise that an actor has
to burst through that you have to
understand even if you get a big project
it may be a bump but it's probably going
to be a slight bump it's more the
accumulation of imbd credits that make a
difference what about getting acclimated
to LA you came from somewhere else I did
and how does one get acclimated to LA
and also acclimated to actors hours
whatever that is well I came from the
East Coast I'd done theater and are you
working up and down the East Coast for
14 years and then I came out expect you
to be much the same and it's not LA is
not really a city it's one thing you
have to understand if you come here it's
a collection of smaller cities geography
is very difficult and your friendships
your ability to do auditions and work is
all determined by traffic and that's a
huge thing to realize when you come here
if you're going to come to LA and try to
be an actor you have to be completely
available emotionally spiritually
physically
your relationships whatever they are
have to understand that this is your
priority Michael Caine said and I think
he's right he said this cannot be if you
want to make it this cannot be just a
full-time job it has to be a full-time
obsession and I find that to be very
true you have to be completely obsessed
to the point that people who are not in
the business will say you're crazy if
they don't say that you're probably not
obsessed enough to make it in the
business what about looking for that
side job while you're looking for those
acting roles that are going to put food
on the table where would you look for
these side jobs and what type of hours
would you look for in terms of those
jobs if you think you have to have a
side job when you first come to LA try
to get one that's very very flexible a
lot of people are bartenders
caterers anything that's part-time don't
get something that's going to lock you
into particular hours every week because
invariably you'll miss an audition and
that's not going to do anything you
might not have gotten the audition but
it kills your morale so I came here with
a no day job plan and it's been tough
you know they've been a lot of peanut
butter years it's good that I'm thin if
you that's another thing if you're going
to come to LA you should probably decide
that you're not going to eat as much as
you thought you might eat or you're
accustomed to eating in the first few
years you have times when you eat
nothing but noodles and peanut butter
that's just the nature of the business
other times you'll have steak but your
day job should be flexible and what do
you wish someone had told you before you
got to LA I wish that before I came that
someone had said don't come because this
is very very difficult
it's a cruel town and a cruel business
no one cares
and you have to do it yourself no I
still would have come but it would have
come with more awareness of just how
difficult this business is all the
people ever see about Hollywood is the
gloss and the entertainment and the
glamour that's all produced for the
general public not for actors I wish
that someone would produce content for
actors say
do not move to Los Angeles it is very
very difficult and then the only people
who will do it are those who'll say bye
damn I'm going to do it I can take it
because that's the kind of spirit you
have to have you have to be tenacious
and you can never ever give up or you
will not make it I think one thing
that's interesting is when people don't
have somewhere to go back to they tend
to stick it out because would you tell
someone on how to emotionally survive
coming here because it is it's very cold
and I think people need an outlet
whether it's reading whether it's hiking
their church whatever it is I hike in
Griffith Park I come to this place every
sunny morning and spend time here and
there's my solace I think you have to
have something outside of yourself a
beauty relationship with God a higher
power your relationships with your
family you have to have other outlets
other than acting because that's what
allows you to you know to put your
passion into your acting at the same
time I know people who never think about
acting except when they have an audition
and I think that's a big mistake you're
a small business person and you have to
think of yourself as a small business
person so when I get up in the morning
I'm going to work when I put my feet on
the floor I'm at work because I am my
business so there's not a moment that
goes by even if I'm hiking even if I'm
reading I'm always looking for things
that I can apply to my business I think
that's the only way you make it we're
entrepreneurs and that's another thing
that people don't say to actors they say
come here and explore your inner self
and and and feel the character well yeah
that's great but first you have to get
on set and you don't do that unless
you're a good businessperson I don't
mean to sound so earnest this is what LA
has done to me this is what LA will do
to an actor if you achieve any type of
success here you become a bit more
serious and then people say boy oh
you're kind of a hard-ass but it's a
tough town
you